Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting
we are beginning what
we're considering a series,
not a week, week, after week series
but a series that we're
going to be revisiting
throughout the year, maybe
years, but starting now,
called, Our Friendship
Throughout The Years.
And we're starting today
by talking about our friendship
in elementary school.
Yeah, I-
The very beginnings.
I'm excited about this because,
I mean, at this table
we've shared many memories-
It it is a table.
Over the episodes, over the years
of our shared experiences
since meeting in first grade.
But I think this is gonna
unearth some new stories
and it's a new lens through which
to kinda look at all of our memories,
specifically the nature of our friendship.
You know, I think that
there's kind of this
oversimplification-
Yeah.
Of the story of,
"Hey, we've been best
for since first grade",
and you just kind of...
You picture us just kind of
going through life together
but when you to dig into
the specifics of it,
again, there's lots of memories that
maybe we haven't accessed or told,
but there's nuances to our friendship
and it definitely has evolved over time
and it's changed with each phase.
Yeah, so we'll be talking about, you know,
our first perceptions of each other,
we'll be talking most,
I'm most excited about giving
you the as true as possible
version of that first day that we met
and the story that we have told
that has become such a part
of how we introduce ourselves to people
and in interviews and stuff like that.
But I think that...
And the further back you go,
so this is as far back as we can go
to the elementary school years,
the more that we kind of
gloss over things because...
It's like, I mean, Who is interested in...
There hasn't been an occasion
for anyone to be like,
"Let's talk about that in more detail"
and so this is stuff that we
haven't even really talked...
A lot of this is stuff we
haven't talked about together
that we've never even reflected on.
Yeah.
'Cause we're...
This is the...
The challenge with us is we've
been through so much together
and we've talked about so much of it
that we start having to find new ways,
if we want to go back
and access old memories,
find new ways to talk about it
and find new memories to explore.
So this is a new sort of
rubric?
I don't use that word very often.
Oh yeah, okay, let's use it.
If at all,
rubric's cube.
Nope, it's not a cube.
I'm gonna
open up rubric's cube
and talk about what I
used to think about Link.
But the plan is...
Yeah, every, I don't know, every month,
every six weeks or so
we'll pick up where we left off
and look at our friendship
through the next phase,
you know, middle school,
high school, college.
Young and married.
Yeah, young and married, young and wild.
And you get the old and wise
or old and whatever we are at this point.
Eventually, it'll just be-
Definitely old-
Us talking about-
And something.
Our current friendship.
Oh yeah.
And I think every phase will be juicy
but let's start with
something really juicy.
Oh, man.
The-
I questioned whether
we should even do this.
Yeah, we did discuss
but whether we should get
into this, but you know what?
I feel like this is, I mean,
it's dimly lit for a reason.
There's a bit of a secretive
trust exercise going here.
So you're in the inner circle.
You're telling...
Don't tell anyone?
You're telling anyone who's listening
to not tell anyone?
Because that-
Well, I feel like this is a special space
where things are discussed that,
hey, if you're into
that, you're here for it
and if you're not, you're missing out.
So once we go through this thing,
I do wanna talk about the stipulations
within which we handle the information
that we've put out there
now, okay?
Okay.
But as a group, as a collective,
but we've mythologized our first meeting
so much over the years that I think...
Well, we've decided that we're
gonna scrutinize this story.
Like from a...
Like, as if we were a detective?
Yeah, so-
If we were a police detective
who was trying to like,
uncover what actually happened.
So first let's tell the story.
Now, we could also sing the story
because at some point we wrote a song.
I actually think writing
that song contributed
to some of the simplification.
So on the...
Here's how it goes,
every single interview, even to this day,
next week if we have an
interview with somebody
for a publication, we will say-
On the first day of first grade
we were both held in from recess
for writing nasty words on our desks.
I wrote
hell.
And I wrote, damn.
I'm not really sure who's says what.
Yeah, sometimes we don't say that.
Yeah.
And we say, yeah.
and that's when we met,
our teacher, Ms. Locklear.
Held us in from recess.
And made us...
Let's just say it together.
Color pictures of mythical beasts.
And that's when we hit it off.
And that's why our company
is called, Mythical
and that's why everything we do
is called something mythical.
And that's why our fans call themselves
Mythical Beasts.
Yes.
Because of that origin story
and you know what? We've
been best friends ever since.
You don't wanna ruin it
for everybody, do you?
Here's the thing,
when we started talking
about this recently, you...
Okay,
I'm gonna say something that
I believe is true about you
and that is, you have an uncanny ability
to look back on something
and change the detail
and then believe it to be true and just,
and bypass the whole, like,
"Ah, this is probably not
exactly what happened."
Like, because there's lots of things
that you've said and I'm like,
"But you know that's actually not, like...
That's actually not true, right?"
That's the way that you've categorized it
and smoothed it out in your mind.
But I don't wanna-
I've always had feelings about this story.
Let's analyze it, and then explain it.
Okay.
I think, yes,
you're on to something.
You're on to something,
but so let's just break it apart.
We did meet
and first of all,
we have not discussed this at length.
No.
It's not like we're about
to confess something to you
that we've concluded that
we've been lying to you.
This is a legitimate exercise right now
in your presence of us analyzing
this mythologized story.
So we certainly met-
I have analyzed it on
my own a few times, but-
We certainly met in first grade.
In Ms. Locklear's class,
in 1984, in Buies Creek.
And we were certainly
both there the first day.
We were definitely both
there the first day.
Now, I'm gonna go back to what I remember.
I'm gonna try to get back
to what I actually remember.
I remember both of us getting in trouble
and I remember both of us
being held in from recess
and I remember both of
us coloring pictures.
And I know-
And judge...
And looking at how you were coloring
and making a judgment about it.
Very...
And early accounts of that story
included the memory from me, of...
Again, now I'm just remembering
the remembering of the memories,
which is what humans do
anyway, this is not just me.
Well, but I'm going back
to what I think is our core
'Cause a couple of things-
Yeah, our core memory.
But there's a couple of things about that
that I'll get into in a second.
I remember Paul Bunyan
and Babe the Blue Ox.
Like, there was a point
when I accessed that
as what I believed to be a core memory
of what we were coloring
or I was coloring.
Now that memory came from you.
Yes.
The fact that it was it was Paul Bunyan,
'cause I don't remember
what we were coloring.
I mean, so I don't have
an opinion about that.
Here's what I believe to...
Here's...
If you put me up against the
wall, here's what I believe.
I don't think it was the first
day of first grade, okay.
I don't think that we were-
It sounds like-
I don't think we got in trouble
on the first day of first grade.
It sounds like a simplification.
I think what happened was we...
It's safe to say that we met in some form
because you pretty much...
In some form
you meet everybody-
Yeah.
In your class on the
first day of first grade.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And that's when you moved from California.
I was there in kindergarten, you weren't.
You know, so I-
And I remember-
We met on the first day of first grade,
but then at some point,
we both got in trouble.
Well, I know we both got in
trouble because I, you know-
But-
Back in the day,
they used to give the-
I could see how-
The numbers on conduct.
Uh-huh.
And it was the higher the
number the worse it was.
Mm-hm.
And if it was a-
Four.
And four was the worst
and I always got fours.
And it...
But the reason I always got fours-
You were talkative.
It's 'cause I just wouldn't shut up.
Self control-
I find it hard to believe-
I got good hygiene.
That I-
Yeah.
They used to rank your hygiene.
Hygiene was on your report card.
Yeah.
I'm sure I did great on that.
Yeah, wait, I wanna talk
about that a little bit.
I find it hard to believe
that I was talkative and
boisterous at that age
because I was...
When I accessed my
feelings from that time,
thank you therapy,
I access a lot of timidity
and early anxiety.
So I-
So it didn't manifest it,
so we'll talk about
first impressions, but-
Me becoming a cut up,
a class later.
A couple of things,
if I had to bet and part
of this is influenced
by the fact that when we met Ms. Locklear,
when we tracked her
down for our documentary
looking for Ms. Locklear,
which you should watch
even though yes you know we found her,
is still...
The spoiler is still worth
it, it's only an hour long.
She told us, and this was not
captured in the documentary.
It was captured, but we
didn't put it in the edit.
Yeah, we edited out.
She was like now-
So we weren't comfortable
then like we are now.
And just-
And at no point had I
thought that the thing about
being held in from recess
together was made up.
No.
But she said,
"I really doubt that I
held y'all in from recess
'cause I've never done
that as a punishment,"
and we were like,
well.
We're gonna edit this out.
Yeah, yeah.
Is what we were thinking.
But I-
Wasn't gonna document.
But I was like ...
But I know.
But like I believe that to be true, like.
Yeah.
And that was a...
There's memories pre being a nasty word,
public figure.
Like, you know,
when you have to like
answer questions by people,
reporters and stuff like that
or you're simplifying things
and you're an entertainment act,
at that point all bets are off.
You're gonna like massage things
and you're gonna tell the big fish story
and the story's gonna be this big.
But back before when I was just
remembering things on my own
and we were remembering things as friends-
Right.
I was 100% sure that we
were held in from recess.
Yeah, we were-
And we were coloring.
We were doing some
interviews for local papers
but it was, you know, and we were...
Maybe there was a temptation
to massage the story
for the documentary or to simplify it
but no, we absolutely believed.
I cannot remember, I don't have...
I cannot visualize getting in trouble
but I know in my heart of hearts
that we did get in trouble.
But I'm 100% sure this
is something I would
bet everything on.
We were not being held in from
recess for writing profanity
on our desks.
We were-
Okay, but
we believed we were
being held in from recess
even though Ms. Locklear said she didn't-
I believe that.
She never did that.
I believe that she did that.
So it's like,
if we weren't held in from recess,
we were punished in some way that I think
it might have been a
succinct way to say it was,
we were held in from recess,
that's a more visceral way to sit to...
A picture to paint than just,
"Oh, we were punished and
we had to color pictures",
like the two of...
The scene that everyone's
outdoors and we are in the room
just the two of us,
I am willing to say
that might not be true.
Okay, but you glossed over something,
Mr. Neil, you glossed over the pun...
What we were being punished for,
I'm saying I am 100%.
Oh no, I'm saying that's the next thing.
Out of whole cloth.
Yeah.
We made up the writing
profanity on our desks.
We, and-
For a while we said,
we didn't remember what we wrote.
Well, here's what we did.
And then we just added what we did right.
Here's what we did.
I agree.
We did not...
I do not believe-
How do you feel right now?
Do you feel deceived?
That we wrote profanity on our desk.
'Cause we...
Neither one of us would've ever done that.
Not right.
You wouldn't have defaced things-
Hell no.
Just out of personal principles.
Damn no.
I would not have defaced things
out of fear of being
murdered by my parents.
I have never defaced anything
in a graffiti-esque type of way-
Yeah.
In my entire life.
I was...
I mean.
Like, I don't think I could
bring myself to do it now.
I mean ironically, we invite people to do
that when we had guests on Ear Biscuits.
Oh, we yeah invited them.
But it wasn't...
You know, we invited them too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But yeah.
I've never done it and so-
I would've never done it.
100% confident that-
That's made up.
I not do that,
but here's my defense
for the lie.
What we said at first was most likely
something to the effect of...
'Cause the reporter will
ask, well, you know,
what were you...
What did you do?
And we're like, well we probably-
Wrote some words on desk.
Probably wrote something,
probably write-
Just made something.
Write on our desk.
We'll say, "Oh we talked too much."
I remember that the desks
had writing on them.
From previous generations.
From other people.
And that is something
that you would've gotten
in trouble for.
I think that happened during the song,
by the way, the song composition.
I think we probably said
something like before the song,
you know what,
we were probably scribbling
on our desks like, oh,
and then the reporter's like,
"What were you writing?"
And we're like, "Well, we
gotta come up with something,"
it's like, "Oh, I don't know.
We might have been writing profanity."
You know, it was probably just
like couched and hypothetical
that then the next time we
told the story, it was like,
you know what?
That was a better story,
we're gonna keep it
couched and hypothetical
but we're gonna tell it more
succinctly and then over time
the succinct ability of it
removes the hypothetical.
Well, and I think...
Here's my defense.
And then you write a song.
Here's my defense of
how this happens, okay.
And I honestly, I don't have any idea
how people are perceiving this right now.
If they're like...
They're whole...
If they're like disappointed,
I don't know what it is.
But like I've always seen
this story of how we met
as like a comedy routine
that is based in something
that actually happened,
but like no standup
comedian who tells the story
is telling you something
that happened to them
exactly the way that it happened to them,
they are taking what happened
and then they are mythologizing
it in a way to make it funny
and entertaining because
their job is not a historian,
their job is a comedian, right.
Is this argument working?
And so-
I don't fully buy it.
But now, but no,
but now, but so I mean.
But it is, yeah.
When a stand up comedian is like,
listen on the way here...
And that's a lie, okay.
If they say that something
just happened to them today,
100% of the time it did not
happen to them that day, okay.
If you live in the world and by the way-
I do live in the world.
Nobody watches
the the late night shows anymore,
but if you go on the late...
If you're on the late night
show and all of a sudden
the actor has like a funny
story, that's all rehearsed, okay
it's not like they're just like,
"You know what, what you just said, Jimmy,
just made me think of this thing,"
it's all rehearsed.
Sorry if you didn't already know that
but I think that this is
the entertainment version
of Rhett and Link,
having a cool packaged
story that is largely true-
Largely true.
But embellished to a point-
So large.
To make it snappy and funny.
Yeah.
And I mean...
And at least we're coming out
and saying that's the case.
And I do think
there's an evolution of the hypothetical
to just leaving out the
phrase of the hypothetical
is just a thing of rhythm
that I'm very good at doing,
I'm just like,
you know what? This is a
better way to tell the story,
it still feels hypothetical
and then after a while it stops
feeling hypothetical to me.
Here's the best example of that
just as a little aside,
we'll come back to the origin story
because this just always just crack me up.
Yeah.
So, you know our story after
we graduated from college,
we were engineers from a while
and then we went on staff with
Campus Crusade For Christ,
the missionary organization
that we were involved in
as students, right.
So we were like college
missionaries for a couple of years
going around telling people
how to tell people about Jesus,
right.
And so, but in order to do that,
if you're gonna go on staff or crew
you have to raise support
which means you have to go
and ask people for money.
Like sit down with
individuals and families
and organizations
and do a presentation.
You do a presentation.
You go to somebody's home and
you break out your laptop,
you do a little presentation and you say,
"So, would you be interested in giving us
or supporting our mission a $100 a month
or something like that?"
Yeah, I had to explain why the two of us
were gonna be speakers
and seminar creators
and resident comedians and filmmakers.
Like, how do you make sense of that?
Right.
Well, you talk about the
stories from our past
of how we did that.
Right.
Which we did a lot of that.
Yeah, yeah.
But the evolution of how
it came about was like
right at the time we were raising support
was when me and you had
become like a comedy duo
who was like making stuff
together and singing together
and doing conferences and stuff like that,
but during college I was MCing with Greg.
As a sidekick.
And then you were leading
with the worship team.
Yeah.
And we weren't doing comedy together,
we would make video...
We would make the videos together.
Like, you would film the videos
of me and Greg and stuff.
But like that's too complicated to explain
to a 65 year old dude
who's just sitting there
falling asleep and just wants to hear you
tell people about Jesus.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
So you simplify.
I understand the motivation.
Greg...
I became Greg in the
story slowly over time.
But I...
But my theory is
is that after telling
the story a few times
you believe that to be the case an it was-
I think Kristy did too.
'Cause she was there.
She never said,
"You know what?
The story's changed.
You know, Greg used to be in there,
now you're just Greg too."
If we can get a chance to
talk to Greg about this.
Yeah.
We-
We need to...
But, okay.
But back to the story.
So you were saying that the-
So I don't think it was the first day.
I don't think...
Ms. Locklear doesn't
think we were held in.
We know that we weren't writing
nasty words on the desk,
we don't know what it was.
I think we got in trouble
but I think that the coloring
was maybe not the punishment
but I have a visceral
memory of sitting down
and watching you coloring
right next to you.
Always in my mind was just the
two of us in the classroom.
But I believe the fact...
The only real fact that I could defend
is that I once sat next to you and colored
and made observations about the nature
of the way you were coloring,
and I was like, "Wow, he's
like really precise, it's like-
Mm-hm. Go on.
What is he try...
Like, I remember thinking like,
"What is he trying to prove?"
It was like...
'Cause I-
What did I prove?
'Cause first grade-
Go on.
You know what I'm saying?
First grade is like, most kids
in first grade are just like,
they're holding...
This is what I was doing.
You're holding the crayon like this.
Like a Neanderthal.
Like you're holding it like
you're gonna kill somebody.
You're gonna like stab
somebody with a crayon.
And then it just makes
contact with the paper
and you just move it.
And I'm just like,
"Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah"
and then I look-
Me not know what wheel is.
And you're like,
it's like, really even I'm like,
"Wow, is he submitting this to a contest?"
'Cause I didn't know this was a contest
and now I need to try,
you know what I'm saying?
Oh no, this is just art time,
I'm not interested in this.
But I know that that happened,
but I'm not willing to
stand by the fact that
that those two events coincided
and it was actually while
we were being punished.
Well, sounds like at least three events
have been combined into one.
You remember us coloring.
Yeah.
We know we met on the
first day of first grade.
Had too.
And we know we got in
trouble at some point
at the same time?
Well, I'm sure that that happened.
Okay.
So those three things were compiled
into one mythologized origin story.
Is there any other part of
this that we need to analyze
or is that it?
'Cause I'm not gonna...
If we're gonna come
clean it's gonna be now,
I'm not gonna...
I don't wanna come back to this feeling.
The last where it all started
to fall apart, you know?
Yeah, right.
This is what happens.
We came clean.
It's all fallen apart,
including our friendship.
I mean-
Hmm.
And from that point on,
so I'll just move on then
'cause I don't think
there's anything else.
Well, no-
From that point on we were best friends
and I think the analysis
of the rest of this episode
will call that into question.
Well, I...
The only thing I'll say is
I'm not changing the story
at this point.
I'm not...
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
So let's decide.
I want to establish for
all of you listening-
How we're going to tell the origin story.
That the next time you're
listening to an interview
or us talk to somebody
and tell this story-
It's gonna be the same.
We're going to say
the exact same thing we've always said,
we're not gonna change it and be like,
"You know, well, really what happened was
is we just met in first grade."
We're gonna tell the entertaining,
embellished mythology of our friendship.
And we're gonna tell it
until the day we die.
And you know what?
There'll be a little twinkle in our eye
because you'll know the truth
and nobody's getting hurt.
Nobody's getting hurt, okay.
Right?
We're all-
What's at stake here?
We're all in this together.
What's at stake here,
right?
We're all in this together.
Does it really matter?
If it comes out that it's
all a sham and it's not,
by the way we never said it was.
Well you shouldn't have
used that word then.
It's an amalgamation of truth simplified
into a compelling narrative
and if you want to mess that up,
well, you're implicating yourself.
Mm.
Yeah.
Okay.
But so we are trusting you
and we're gonna keep telling that story
and I'm gonna have a hard
time for the next year or so,
but then I'll get over.
Here's-
I'll probably forget this conversation.
Here's some-
And be cool with it again.
Here's something that I...
Here, I'll go out on another limb here.
Do it.
And say that if this, you know,
you should analyze how this makes you feel
if you're listening to this.
Mm-hm.
Because what you probably
should understand
is that the vast majority
of news and history
pretty much follows what we did.
Not only that.
You ever read the Bible?
Oh God.
Not only that, I would say you're...
Take a hard look at your own experience
and your own memories.
Your memories are a
recollection of memories.
Every time you remember something,
we talked about this,
you're reconstructing
the memory in your brain
and if some...
And it evolves.
Yeah.
This is science.
So we're all in this together.
Yeah.
Like I was saying.
And at least we came clean.
We're so defensive right now.
No, I just...
I feel good.
I feel good about it.
Well, I mean.
I think it was hilarious.
I feel great.
We feel so great.
We feel great.
I can tell that we both
feel great about it.
We're so proud of ourselves.
It is canon.
Let's talk a little
bit about this T-shirt,
you know, I was gonna put it on
but I'm a little cold
in the studio right now.
I mean, it looks good on the hanger.
This is the, Hot Dog Is a
Sandwich podcast T-shirt,
you know, Mythical Kitchen.
They have their own podcast,
Hot Dog Is a Sandwich.
You know who else-
Josh and Nicole.
Do you know who else has a podcast now?
Trevor's got a podcast.
Of course he does.
Trevor Talks Too Much.
Yeah.
First episode with Brittany
Broski is already out
as of the release of this
episode right now, fresh.
Listen to Trevor Talks Too Much,
he's good at talking
right from episode one.
Very proud of him, very-
Yeah, he's got a gift.
Very glad that we've done it.
He's got a gift of gab.
Taking full credit for
everything he accomplishes
over there.
Trevor Talks Too Much,
Hot Dog is a Sandwich,
expanding offerings of Mythical podcast.
Get in where you fit in,
you know.
I would like to talk a little
bit about first impressions
as I remember them.
Okay.
We've already talked a little
bit about my impression
of like how you were coloring.
coloring.
But, and I actually didn't...
I had to kind of dig back and think like,
"What do I remember thinking
about Link in meeting him?"
Now, I've already established
that my Mo was to...
I was...
I wasn't...
I didn't perceive you as timid
but I know that I definitely was not timid
in terms of my...
I threw myself at people, right,
in a way that I don't do now.
Like, I'm more of an introvert
but I was a weird extrovert
in like elementary school
in the way that I would
just like meet somebody
and then within the first five minutes
invite myself to spend the
night at their house that night,
I did it with anybody.
And so I was very drawn to just like-
Now I'm wondering if
everything you're saying
is an oversimplification.
Like, the first time you met them
you'd invite yourself over to their house.
That's an oversimplification.
It is.
But very, very early,
like alarmingly early,
usually in the first day I would be like,
"Hey, so like, what do you
think about sleepovers?"
I know, I would be like...
Its just I'd find a way,
that's all true.
So I was...
But I would, you know,
I was kind of evaluating like,
"Oh, this person seems...
There's something here
like, this person seems like
they'd be fun or like we could
have a good time together",
right.
Mm-hm.
So obviously I thought that about you
because I'm pretty sure we
had sleepovers in first grade,
but here's the thing that
I remember about you.
I find that hard to believe.
Okay, maybe I didn't.
That seems really early for me.
Okay.
I remember thinking that
you were very clean.
Clean?
Speaking of hygiene,
that you were like very put together
like you had this like, your
hair was like, it's like,
somebody's...
Like, he really is caring
about like his hair
and his clothes.
Somebody's combing that head of hair.
His hair is combed,
his clothes like match.
Like, someone is like laying
them out or he cares about it.
Like, you know, I'm wearing
like gray sweat pants
and a gray sweatshirt.
You're like, that's an outfit, I'm there.
You know what I mean?
And like, you're like,
"I only have a blue Coke
shirt and yellow Coke pants."
And like, you know what I'm saying?
And that...
I know this wasn't just first grade
but I remember thinking that it was like,
but I didn't process it,
you know, I'm first grade.
So I'm looking back and
thinking that, like,
what did you think about-
Do you remember like-
This kid.
On the first day of a grade, would you...
I mean early on, would your parents-
Not first grade.
Would your parents put you in an outfit
and take your picture?
No.
Yeah.
Every year I would be putting an outfit
and my mom would take my picture
with like my new trapper
keeper and my lunchbox
and I'm standing in front
of the closet and you know,
I'm going to school and boy,
this is really built up
and I don't know how I feel about this.
I think my parents were just happy-
My anus is very tight right now.
Oh gosh.
I think my parents were just
happy to get us to school
without someone dying.
You had an older brother too.
Yeah.
It was just like, this
is old news to them.
Yeah, the sweat...
Just put on your sweats.
It's like, what are you gonna do?
You're gonna go out and you're
gonna play some B-ball and-
And I had a...
I don't know if in first grade
I didn't have a buzz cut in first grade,
but like it pretty early
on, I was just like,
they were just like,
let's just head into the
barbershop and put it on level one.
Like me and my brother just had ones
just like.
It's like...
It was like a military family
but it really wasn't.
It was a family that
just didn't care about
just like, okay, well
you go to school like,
we gonna care...
Oh, we care what you look
like when you go to church
and we care what you look
like on picture day, sorta.
Sorta.
But not really.
Yeah, for me it's like, you know,
I was an only child and
it was like, you know,
my mom was like, I was her little baby.
So like, she's like doing,
you know, she's like,
"Everything's gotta be right
for little Linky", you know.
But for you it's like, you're the second
and it's...
There's also two opinions in your house.
So it's like, even if your
dad wanted to dress you up
and your mom was like,
"Oh, don't worry about it,
let him wear his sweats" or vice versa-
I'm sure my dad was not, "Lets
dress him" my dad was like-
I'm just giving, you know,
I'm not trying to play into
gender stereotypes here
but I'm just saying
there's two opinions and those opinions
are distributed over two boys.
Whereas me, it's one opinion
that was not throttled,
my mom's opinion that I did not question.
I was like, "Okay yeah,
it's like, oh, this is
how things are done."
I also think it's a
disposition too, because-
Sure.
We actually think about like...
Jesse and I have both had
probably more opinions
than we should have about like,
what our kids wear when they go places,
do you know what I'm saying?
I think it might just be-
Oh yeah, I see.
Just like living in a
more superficial culture
or whatever, but it's kind of like,
"Hey bro, that doesn't match
or your hair looks crazy right now."
Those conversations
didn't happen in my home.
You know what I mean?
It just didn't...
Just that wasn't a part that I remember,
it wasn't a part of things.
It was kinda like, "Yeah, you're
dressed and you're alive."
I'll tell you what-
Get out there.
What wasn't a part of my
life and it was a part,
I know that my hair was
just combed straightforward.
Get a bald cut.
It was combed straightforward.
Yeah.
And there was no...
But it was combed.
It was brushed.
I remember thinking,
"His hair looks like it's cut by a lady."
As a total...
Yeah, a total generalization.
Yeah, it was.
Now her name was-
Not Rudolph Blanchard who was just...
I will say, her name was Bobby though.
Oh really?
She didn't have a man's name.
Okay.
But she's a woman.
No one...
Scissors did not see my hair until
30, the age of 30.
I mean, I went through my whole
twenties cutting my own hair
with Clippers.
I mean like, but scissors, I could see
you had scissors on your hair.
I think-
It was written all over your face.
I'm trying to think what my
first impressions of you were
because
I have to kind of interpellate
from the facts that I know.
I don't...
And maybe I'll access a memory
but nothing specific comes
to mind like it does for you.
It's like, I'm so good...
I made such a strong impression on you.
So many visceral and specific memories.
But it wasn't...
But because it was different.
That's what I'll say that like,
I felt like most of the
other kids sort of seem like,
"Yeah, like we're in first grade.
We're just kind of like-
Going with it.
Existing."
Yeah.
But it was like, "Oh,
this kid is like, he's"-
Put together.
"It's picture day every day for this kid."
Put...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right?
I like that.
Yeah.
Yes, definitely.
And for the reasons that
I mentioned, I think that,
you know, I don't think it
was anything that I analyzed,
it was just the opinions in my life,
basically my mom, were like-
But you don't think that you-
I never questioned it.
You don't think that you-
And I never looked around.
I don't think I...
I was self-conscious.
I do have this early
preschool memory of like,
I was...
The guys were so rambunctious and physical
like, there was like wrestling
happening in preschool
and I was afraid of the guys
and I would always hang
out with the girls.
Like, the guys would
climb this fort structure,
built indoors at the
Littleton First Baptist church
and be up there and I would...
And doing rambunctious stuff
and I was just intimidated
and so I would hang out with the girls.
Well, and no, I didn't...
So there's that-
I didn't know you
at that time.
kindergarten version
of that.
I didn't know you at that time,
but what I do along those lines is that
it was a very quickly-
First grade.
Was like, "He's not interested in sports."
Now again, I wasn't...
I didn't have a-
Yeah.
I've never really been that like...
I'm not a judgemental person,
you know what I'm saying?
So it's not like, "He's
not interested in sports
so therefore he's not my friend" like no-
No, it was like he's-
Process that happened.
Apparently it was, "He's different,
I got to see his house."
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got to spend a night, like-
But it was clear that
like, even in first grade,
I remember in first
grade, first, second grade
talking to other boys about, you know,
like, "Jr Reid's coming to Carolina",
like that's a level of conversation-
.
That I would have with
these other kids who like
cared about college sports
and like what was happening
at Carolina and State and
Duke at the time, right
and a lot of that comes
from the fact that like,
okay, my dad was really into sports
and all these other kids'
dads really into sports.
Yeah.
And I had a brother
and that kind of thing,
but it was like that wasn't a conversation
I was gonna have with you.
It was like,
"Okay, well, I'm gonna have
a different conversation
with this guy.
My first impression of you
had to have been related
to the fact that like you
weren't there the year before
in kindergarten, you were
taller than everybody.
Yeah, I was already a head taller.
Tall and skinny.
You had this look about you.
A look.
It's like, you know,
I'm not gonna-
Like a hawk, like a Falcon.
I'm not gonna say it's Gollumasque
but you had bigger eyes
and you were gangly
and if you-
But you did just say it was Gollumasque.
If you got down on all fours,
I'm not gonna say, that's like...
You know how in like the
Fellowship of the Ring
they put Gollum in there for a few seconds
but you didn't really...
Like, they hadn't fully
figured out who Gollum was.
They hadn't done all the CGI.
So like in two towers,
he's fully fleshed out
and looks different
but in like the first one
he's kind of like this
shadowy new character
that you don't really know and like,
boy, he's really hunched over
and you can kind of count
all of his vertebrae
and boy, there's a...
And he looks like he
has some extra vertebrae
and his eyes are so big.
You're talking-
That's probably what I thought-
You're talking more-
But I'm not gonna say
because I don't remember.
You're talking...
But factually that's not true because
I looked that way during
and shortly after puberty,
I actually was just kind of a tall kid
but proportionally relatively normal.
Okay.
I began looking like
Gollum in ninth grade.
Hey, man.
I was just joking.
Okay. Well, that's a good joke.
It was a good run there.
Now it's worth the 90
seconds that it took.
Let's go...
I'm sure I wasn't the only
one who thoroughly enjoyed it.
So we were...
Let's go through the teachers we had.
Okay.
From first to sixth grade.
First grade, Ms. Locklear class.
Mm-hm.
Second grade
I was in Ms. Bailey's class.
I was in Ms. Lawrence's class.
So we were not in the same class.
Right.
And we can revisit some of these
but I just kind wanna go through it.
Third grade-
I was in Ms. Hood's class.
We were both in Ms. Hood's class.
Mm-hm.
I mean, I remember you
being in Ms. Hood's class.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You remember me being in Ms. Hood's class?
Yeah, yeah.
And that's when Ben...
And that's the year Ben moved
into town from Oklahoma.
Okay.
Third grade.
So I remember really a
liking Ms. Hood's class.
Ms. Hood was great.
She was tough but she was great.
She was a great teacher.
Fourth grade-
Ms. Everhart.
I was in Ms. Rand's class.
Right, yeah.
Now, what happened was
they did this thing where it was like...
By this age all the kids knew
that they were labeled as...
Like, some kids got this AG
label, academically gifted.
Right.
And there was this...
It was something that
everybody knew and it was...
I don't think it was
healthy that we all knew it.
No.
And so then you were kind of
put into different classes
based on that.
It was like, "Oh, you're
in the smart class"
or "You're in the not so smart class."
Ms. Everhart was the smart class.
Ms. Rand was the not so smart class.
Right.
And you're right.
We all kind of like...
We all knew it.
You all knew it.
And the reason why...
I was a smart kid, I think
I was in the AG bucket.
No judge to those who weren't,
I guess maybe I don't want to imply that
but my mom had heard all this stuff
about how Ms. Everhart was
so tough on her students.
"Oh, that she gives so much homework,
she's so...
She pushes them so hard,"
that my mom went to school
and requested that I not get Ms. Everhart.
And then I was...
Ms. Everhart was actually
an incredible teacher.
I know, that's the sad thing about it.
And her room was out in
one of those trailers.
Yeah, she was isolated
so she could get away
with all types of stuff.
My mom didn't want
didn't want little Linky
to have to suffer through.
And the smart kids, by the way,
got a computer.
Did you all have a
computer in your classroom.
Uh-uh.
Yeah, we had like two, they gave two,
they gave us two computers
and they gave y'all zero computers.
I'm sorry, man.
Your mom screwed that one up big time.
And that was the year I'll learned
my multiplication tables.
And I learned how to beat Oregon Trail.
Yeah, I didn't get to play.
I had to go to the library
to play Oregon Trail.
Yeah.
I could do it anytime I wanted.
Man, I remember...
Well, I'm not gonna talk.
I'm not gonna talk about
my teacher but it was like,
yeah the classes,
it just wasn't the same-
Caliber.
Fifth grade, I was in Ms. Hobbs class.
Hobbs, Ms. Hobbs.
I couldn't remember if you were in there.
Yeah.
My big thing about that year,
my claim to fame was that's when I won
the anti-drug poster contest
and had to travel with Ms. Hobbs
to the Kiwanis Club dinner
at the Western Sizzlin in Dunn.
We haven't given the update,
I not gonna do it now
but just as a reminder
we haven't given the update
about what we learned about...
We met someone who knew
about the posters contest.
I need to get the full
story and report back.
From Cole.
Yeah, from my brother.
Your brother.
My brother met someone who was in charge
of choosing the winner of that contest.
The other thing I remember...
Oh, wow.
The other thing I remember from Ms. Hobbs
was she was pregnant that year.
Mm-hm.
And lots of times she was
not in a good head space.
I remember her seeming
a little bit perturbed
with the children, yeah.
Yeah, she had a short fuse
and a very pregnant belly.
Yeah.
It's like, I...
In retrospect, I kind of feel for-
Oh yeah. Could you imagine?
But now I was like...
I was like, "What is
wrong with this woman?
I mean, I know that she's
pregnant, but I mean,
what's her problem?"
She was a-
Now I'm like-
Good teacher though.
Good gosh.
She was a good teacher.
Learned a lot of math in that class.
Yeah.
And then in six grade I was
in Ms. Campbell's class.
And I was in Ms. Leneer's class.
Ms. Leneer's class.
And at that point-
I really feel like I missed
out on Ms. Leneer's class
but Ms. Campbell was super sweet.
It was a combination class.
So there was some...
It was the smart sixth graders
and the not as smart seventh graders.
Yeah, right.
That's yeah.
That's really how it worked.
Yeah, it's pretty simple.
You know, it's...
We haven't really thought
about it in a while
that like, every year...
We met in first grade
then every other year
we weren't in the same class.
Yeah.
So, and you have this memory
of like, from the beginning
going on sleepovers to people's homes,
in the Book of Mythicality,
if you're into this type of conversation
and you haven't gotten your
copy of the Book of Mythicality
get one because there's stories
that we're not gonna share here
and lots of other stories from
our shared best friendship,
even though now we're dismantling it.
Available in audio book
form as well that we read.
Oh, probably even better.
I don't remember spending a night.
I remember I told the story
spending the night at Zach West's house
and then he pile drived me.
Mm.
And he wasn't best friend material,
is how I put it in the book.
Right.
I think I spent the night at
Matthew Enzor's house once
and his dad, Benny, was
watching Alien and like,
I felt really uncomfortable.
So yeah.
It's just like-
I don't know, man.
I just remember feeling uncomfortable
in other environments.
Like, I was only comfortable at home
so I can believe that if
you invited yourself over
to my house, I wasn't gonna say no,
I would be like, "Sure."
But I would not have been
comfortable going to your house
at such an early age.
Oh, I didn't invite people to my house
'cause I already know about that.
Okay, so-
I didn't have sleepovers
at my house until...
Like, very few of these people.
Probably sixth grade, maybe seventh grade.
Yeah.
So, okay my-
And that's when I would've
started spending the night
at your house.
My perspective on this is that...
Again, the way that my brain works
is that I don't...
Especially at the time, I
didn't like categorize people,
right.
And so if you asked me in first grade,
"Who's your best friend?"
I'd be like,
"I got lots of friends",
and I would probably answer
that question the same way.
I would say that it
was probably like third
and fourth grade after
Ben moved into town.
Yeah.
It was probably, especially that year,
the Ms. Everhart year where
we were not in the same class.
Yeah.
Where I would've said
Ben was my best friend
if you would've put me up against a wall.
But I did not think in terms.
Maybe not and there's a
reason I'll give in a minute
but-
I didn't think in terms of-
I'm not surprised by this, yeah.
I makes sense.
I didn't think in terms of that,
it was more just like
there's people that I like
to hang out with a whole lot.
But everybody, like...
If I mention any guy,
tell me if you spend
the night at his house,
Adam.
Yeah.
David R.
Yes.
You didn't...
Let's see who,
the Enzor's, did you spend
Matthew Enzor's house?
Not...
Definitely at least a couple of times
but I don't remember exactly.
It may have been a little bit later.
Tate Maddox.
Oh yeah, multiple times.
Who else?
Zach.
You spent a night at Zach's house?
Oh yeah.
Julian.
Oh, Julian, skateboarder?
Yeah.
Oh, he was too intimidating.
And I think Chris too.
Chris Morris?
I think so.
Of course, Peter.
Peter Dinklage, not the Peter Dinklage.
Well, he was your neighbor,
so you'd walk over.
He was younger too.
You would spend a night at
somebody a year younger?
You got a house, you got
a fridge, you got a TV,
I'm there.
So you would-
Justine.
Oh, Justin?
Mm-hm.
You'd go around the
corner to Justin's house?
Every kid in my neighborhood
was on the list.
Michael Jubi, he was in the mix.
Oh yes, Michael Jubi had the best house.
He had that-
Had a loft with a spiral staircase.
Loft thing with a spiral staircase.
And he was on a golf course.
Oh yeah.
Whole 13 at the time on Keith Hills, man.
And his parents were fun to talk to.
His parents were so cool.
So cool.
Yeah, man.
Let's see.
I didn't spend the night at
any of these people's houses
ever.
I was gregarious, man.
I was up for a good time.
That...
When Adam Nicholson had that
sleepover for his birthday
and we watched Texas Chainsaw Massacre,
that may have been the
first time I spent the night
at anyone's house and that
was probably seventh grade,
sixth grade.
Really?
Yeah.
I mean-
I can name 10 more, by the way, if you...
I need a yearbook.
Okay.
We won't get into it.
You know, Brooks.
I don't...
Okay, so Brooks was younger too.
Two years younger, but we were-
But he was a family friend.
We were...
Our families were really close.
And what...
So, and you loved it.
You were never like, "Get me outta here"?
No, man.
I...
Here's the thing, I-
I mean, we're so different in this way.
But this is something-
But it didn't register, that's the thing.
No, but this is something that
I didn't know about myself
and I've never really thought about it,
but like I, especially back in the day,
I don't feel like I do
this as much anymore,
but like I would find the
way to connect with somebody.
I would be like, this is
the thing that they're into
and it's just like, I'm into everything
so when I go to this person's house
all we talk about is this.
And you know-
I didn't dictate what we talked about.
It was like this person's into this,
"This person's really into Nintendo,
well, I can be really into Nintendo."
You spent the night at
Chad Leander's house?
Yes.
And just played Nintendo,
just like he would do a
speed run through it all?
I think it was one...
I think one time.
Okay.
But...
And it's funny because
now that I've learned more
about the Enneagram, you know,
one of the things they
call the Enneagram three
is the chameleon, right.
Hm.
It's a person who-
Blends in.
Can enter into a environment
and immediately be like,
"This is what we're doing here?
All right, this is what I'm doing.
If that's what makes everybody happy,
that's what I'm gonna do."
And that brought me joy.
And you had a really
stable home life, you know,
I think, and it...
I'm doing some work now to
kind of go back to that point
and this is kind of helpful.
Like, I'm not gonna bring it up here
like, I'm not gonna bring the
therapy component into this
except to say...
Maybe later but for now
the only thing I'll say
is that like, yeah,
I'm coming to grips with the
fact that like, you know,
my mom did an excellent job.
I'm not critiquing anything
she did with the hand
that was dealt her but it was not...
I had this perception of it,
it was not a stable environment, you know?
And I had this really keen sense of like
just a gut feeling of lack of
safety outside of the home.
That's an oversimplification
and maybe an over dramatization of it,
but it was like
that's kind of how I
ventured into the world
was with trepidation.
Yeah.
So, you know,
when you were spending the
night at people's homes,
like, what was I doing? I was
doing my own thing at home
like watching this new
thing called Nickelodeon
on channel 34.
I didn't have cable,
that was another reason
I had to get to other people's homes,
they had cable.
And then I would do some
exploring in the woods
and all the stuff around my house alone.
I would pretend to be an
army guy who was like-
Yeah.
And like a commando.
And we-
And we had the-
So you remember those duck
boots that everybody had
and on the back of them
they said "Explorers"?
Uh-huh.
Because I think it was like
an addition of that duck boot.
Yeah.
So Cole and I had those
and then Jeremy Fisher
down the street had those boots as well,
and so we were the explorers
but that was again,
that was with-
Neighborhood kids.
Yeah, that was my older
brother, three years older.
I Didn't have any-
And so we would go-
Neighborhood kids either.
Like name the forks and stuff like that
but like.
My community wasn't like that,
we we're on opposite sides of the town.
Right.
So...
But I think one of the main
forces that brought us together
and it superseded school
and then might change a little
bit of the complexion of like
what would've been in your
mind as a fourth grader saying
that Ben was your best friend,
which you certainly would've said,
but would've kind of put me in
that conversation was church.
Yeah.
You know, from the moment you moved there
you joined Buies Creek
First Baptist Church.
The church that me and mom and
my stepdad, Jimmy, went to.
So we were at that church.
Why do you think your
parents chose that church?
I think Jimmy had a
connection to that church
that went further back, so
it was like there was like
a longer established connection there,
but...
And then I was very...
We were both very involved.
Your parents were very involved.
My mom, if she could pull
everything together in time
to get to church on time.
Yeah.
She was gonna be there but she, you know,
she had a hard time getting ready
to the point where at a
certain point I'd be like,
"Mom, you need to stop halfway
in your like, makeup and hair routine
to bring me to church because
the kids are making fun of me
for being late for church
every Sunday morning
for Sunday school."
And then she would come back and like
show up halfway through
the Sunday school lesson
or just show up at church.
She could not get herself ready.
Wow.
But yeah, we would Sunday school
and church every Sunday morning,
every Wednesday night there'd be something
and then there was usually
another night of the week
that we were at church.
So it was like,
even the years that we
weren't in the same class
we were spending like
our youth group time-
Yeah, that's true.
And church time together and like,
so, and we were very close in that world.
Like, if you think of everybody
else that went to church...
Who were the other guys
that went to church with us?
There wasn't...
Like, Matthew McKinney
went to church with us
And Matthew and John.
Matthew, and John Enzor.
But, so it was a smaller group that like
we were the closest to each.
Yeah, yeah.
But by that time I would've-
And so...
And that was from an early time.
And by third grade...
Third, fourth, fifth, sixth grade
I would not have said that
any of those other kids
that I had spent the night
with were my best friends.
Yeah.
I would be like, my
friends are Ben and Link.
Yeah.
In terms of like my friends my age
and then I would be...
And I think I would've been like,
and I hang out with Brooks
quite a bit too, but yeah.
Sports...
Yeah, when you talk about Brooks.
Sports was such a big part
of your like, basketball.
Yeah.
Like, you played everything,
you played baseball,
you played soccer.
I played soccer from...
That was the big thing in Buies Creek,
everybody...
That was like a five, six
and seven year old team,
recreation team.
Like, they started you really young.
It was like very organized
the what, basketball
recreation didn't exist.
Yeah.
Baseball recreation didn't exist.
But like, it was interesting
that soccer was the thing
that was like really exploding
in like the late eighties.
And so-
And Campbell had a really good team.
That's right.
So like,
I always played soccer
and had enough confidence
to at times, begin to enjoy
it but not any other sports
but you were into every sport.
So we didn't connect in that way
but I played all the other
sports all the way through,
you know, up until...
Yeah, like baseball started
at like maybe sixth grade.
Mm-hm.
And I did play, boy, I hated that,
maybe fifth grade.
Yeah.
But...
So a little bit of soccer
but it was mainly church
and like your parents
were so committed to it,
and I kind of folded
in underneath that like
level of commitment that
was like, I was, I mean,
as we've established from a young age,
you followed your parents' example
and I kind of followed
your family's example
of like being super committed.
Yeah.
It was like that was
from an very early age,
our identity as people was-
Right.
Our evangelical belief system,
even in contrast to the
other church across town,
Memorial Baptist and say,
"Oh, they're the more liberal church"
and like, we had friends from school
who went to that church but
we thought of them differently
because it wasn't...
They weren't as
fervent in our opinion as we were.
I mean, that's a whole
story in and of itself
is just, yeah,
there's a saying for that,
there's something of minor differences
I can't remember what it is,
but it says that, "You've
got to have an enemy"
and in this little teeny tiny town
there's two main churches
that are two Baptist churches
and those two Baptist
churches have to find a way
to look down on one
another, it's just so crazy
that that's the way humans work.
Because there were...
I mean, read the Lost
Causes of Bleak Creek
you'll see how he folded
that into the novel, but...
And there weren't many people,
we didn't have many classmates
who didn't go to one church
or the other, you know, so it was really,
that's why there was such a dichotomy.
It's like everybody went
to one church or the other.
And we were getting closer
to the group of kids
that were our age that
were at church as well.
And as we got older,
you know, you start
taking it more seriously.
Oh yeah.
And so then the fact that
you take this very seriously
and like, you believe in God
in this very particular way
and you practice that belief
then you start making
connections with people.
Right.
And also there's like the whole like,
you start kind of drawing
some political lines
because that's part of it as well
and of course we're talking early nineties
south, by that time, the Christian right
had pretty much taken hold
in the conservative party-
Mm-hm.
So republicans, so it was just like,
"Oh, are you a Democrat or Republican?"
Right.
So it's like you needed to
be a Republican Christian
in order to be like,
really in on the in club
and that was beginning...
That was starting to filter in the way
that we were thinking, right.
Yeah.
And I remember even, you
know, around like fifth,
sixth grade, Ben started
to kind of experience
some of the issues that-
The tension 'cause he
went to Memorial Baptist.
Well, but also he was always
such a open-minded like-
Yeah.
Challenging thinker, his parents were too.
'Cause his family was.
And so it's just like that started
to get a little complicated
as I'm like getting serious about this,
it's kind of like.
Yeah, it's like your
dad was a law professor.
He's not really into this.
He's got more questions about this.
But Ben's dad was a
biology professor, right?
Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
So it's like, you know,
you can definitely see that vibe.
Right.
Of like, you know,
the rule following versus the-
Well, but coupled with the fact that
Ben was also beginning to
experience some emotional things
and some physical things.
Right.
Like trying to figure out
has he got chronic fatigue
whatever,
I can't remember exactly when that started
to manifest itself, but
that began to complicate.
It's difficult for kids to understand
how to navigate a friendship
when someone's going through
stuff like that.
Which again,
we'll refer to the other
podcast that, you know,
where we talked at length about
Ben, our other best friend,
so we don't have to
get back into that now.
But I mean, we certainly
connected over like
being out in nature,
so even though you spend a lot
of time playing basketball,
as we got into these
older elementary grades,
like you were...
I was more comfortable coming
out of my shell, you know,
gramping up into middle school and like
starting to get like...
We connected over like being in nature
and I got in on what
you and Ben were doing.
But back to the church thing, I mean,
our first teacher, I
remember was Ms. Tolsma.
Tosome, something like that.
She-
I do not remember her.
She was my neighbor across this street
and she was our Sunday
school teacher at fist.
Was she blonde and had all the kids?
She had the two twins who were blonde.
The blonde twins.
Oh good gosh.
Really?
The fantasies,
the fantasies
of just going over there and swinging
on the swing set with those blonde twins.
Yeah.
That's all I wanted.
I Didn't remember.
I just wanted to swing with them.
I didn't remember being into them.
But that was kind of like a
normal Sunday school teacher.
You and I, feet like you
had different tastes-
Mom.
In women.
But my point is
she was a normal Sunday school teacher
but then Ms. Clark showed up.
You remember Ms. Clark?
Oh, okay, now we're
talking, now I remember.
Ms. Clark, you know,
had a son who was a
year older than us, Sam.
Yeah, yeah, yah.
And her husband was, he was
a science guy at Campbell.
Well, they lived in that
house that like the,
not the Campbell house but
near the Campbell house
where like people who were
in town working at Campbell
would like live for a little bit.
He was a professor, but he had just...
They had...
Yeah, somehow they just moved in
and they were very associated
with the school and...
But she was very scholarly
and kind of this like
homeschool precursor type thing.
So like when we went to
her Sunday school class
it wasn't just like, "Hey,
here's a nice Bible story
and you're gonna have
some prayer and a craft,"
no, this was intense education.
Like, "This is what grace
means, this is what mercy means,
this is how they don't
mean the same thing."
And it's like posted all over the-
Yeah, we were being
indoctrinated real hard.
And it was...
Yeah, she was...
Very effectively.
It was very intense.
Yeah.
And she was a...
I wouldn't say a...
How would I describe her?
Scholarly, intense, proper,
like prim and proper.
It was kinda like if she
could have had a ruler
and smacked you on the hand,
it was almost like if it was, you know,
a couple of decades earlier she'd been-
She was from the old school.
In that old school vibe.
And again, this is just Sunday school.
This is just an elective thing.
But you know, one of the
things that I think is
a significant about this
is that kids respond to
this type of instruction
and let's just be honest,
this type of indoctrination
in different ways.
Some kids sniff it out and
are like, "I'm not into this"
and they rebel at that point
and they kind of check out,
even though our personalities
were very different-
Mm-hm.
We both locked in on this
thing and we're like,
for whatever reason, this is
it, man, this is important
like, I got to listen to these people,
I got to be about this
and I think that the fact that we both
latched onto it so hard-
Really brought us together.
Is really what made us such good friends.
Yeah.
Leading into middle school.
Even if we weren't in the same class,
we didn't see each other at
school for every other year.
Yeah.
That's absolutely what did it, you know,
and she was also artsy.
She didn't write it but
she brought in this play,
The Bible Tells Me So Show.
Mm, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That was her, huh?
Yep.
Her son, Sam was like, a
gifted actor and singer
and very charismatic and
like larger than life
but in retrospect I it think was,
okay, she can't cast her own
son to be the starring role
of this because-
The host of the show.
You know, it was The
Bible Tells Me So Show-
It feels like a game show.
It was a spoof of Family Feud
if Family Feud was just
about Bible trivia.
Yeah.
And then the two teams that competed that
which like the two families
were friend groups.
So it's like all the...
They were like all kids in a youth group
that knew each other, so
there was like some sort...
I wouldn't call it drama
but there was interplay,
friendship interplay between them.
As part of the story.
Christian interplay.
As part of the story that
rounded out it being-
'Cause we were all in
the same youth group.
Yeah.
So she couldn't cast her
own son to be the star,
which he clearly needed to be.
Yeah.
As I recall, that would be the case.
And so she cast me to be the host of
The Bible Tells Me So Show.
I remember you getting that part,
and this was at a time that I
was like any sort of like...
I was about being a class
clown and like, you know,
cutting up and getting
attention in that way.
I was too.
And you were too
but when it came to like,
this is organized and
somebody else is dictating
what this is I was always
like, "This is not for me"
but then-
Well, especially because it was a play.
But yeah, yeah.
Like, I had this-
We didn't think we were the drama kids.
Right, right.
But I remember you getting
cast as that and it's like,
now I'm thinking back to what
I must have been thinking
and be like, well, you know what?
He is very clean.
Like a host, like a TV host.
Yeah, he's like, he's very put together.
Like, this is good casting.
You know what I'm saying?
You're not gonna give
the kid with the buzz
the hosting job 'cause it's
like, you had like hair,
like you had hair that
could be like combed into a-
And at Easter I would
wear suits to church-
Yeah, yeah.
So I had a few suits.
You had, yeah.
You had a blazer, at least one.
Yeah.
Right, yeah.
I think it was pretty good casting.
I think Sam would've
taken it to gone too hard.
He def would've gone too hard.
He went so hard at everything.
Yeah, so, I mean, you were in the play.
I was on one of the teams.
All the youth group were there
but I had so-
Good answer, good answer.
I had so many lines.
That was one of my lines.
And it was a musical.
♪ When I see trees ♪
Hold on.
♪ Waving in the breeze. ♪
You had to sing that?
♪ And hear the birds in the air ♪
♪ I thank the Lord for all
that he has done this. ♪
It's amazing that you remember this.
♪ To show me he cares ♪
You don't remember that?
No, man.
I don't remember that, dude.
♪ Oh, give thanks to the Lord ♪
♪ For he is good to all ♪
This is why there's two of us.
I remember certain things
and remembers other things
♪ He sends the sun to light our day ♪
♪ And helps the rain to fall ♪
No, hold on.
Do you think you could
sing this without the fact
that you found it on video?
I found the video, I didn't watch it.
I remember this stuff from
then absofreakinlutely.
Really?
The thing that I-
It's crazy.
And what I wanna do is,
I want to digitize the...
I've got this VHS, it's got
my mom's handwriting on it,
she kept it all these
years and now I have it.
Let's put that-
I wanna digitize
The Bible tells me so show.
On the society.
Let's put it on the
society and we'll like,
do a director's commentary...
Well, we didn't direct it.
We'll get Ms. Clark to do it.
I love Ms. Clark.
No, we'll do a participant
and actor's commentary
over this thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is a really good idea.
I think we kind of have to
put it on the Mythical Society
just because that's where
it makes the most sense
and there might be
rights issues otherwise.
That's what the Mythical
Society is all about, man.
Yeah.
It's about the coolest stuff.
I remember all the
songs, but I'll tell you
what I don't remember, any of my lines.
Even at the time, I remember
drilling my lines...
I had a stack of stuff, I
had so many freaking lines.
Weren't you at one point in the baptismal?
Didn't the baptismal open
up and you said something?
I don't think so.
In my mind that's what happened.
I had the script on the pulpit
and I would flip the script
and I'd follow it along.
I couldn't memorize all the lines.
Did we do that on a Sunday morning?
Did they give us the service?
I don't know, maybe.
Or was it like it come to
this thing on Wednesday night.
But it was such, you know, there was...
We were so...
Like, the youth group was
like so much of our identity
and like you said, it
really brought us together
and it was like our youth
group against the world,
against...
Like, when we went in they
would talk in terms of like,
when you go into school it's
like you support each other
and you hold each other accountable
to the things that we're committed to.
But we were developing this
incredibly tribalistic mindset, right.
And I'm using that
in terms of how hard you
identify with another group
of people and an ideology
to the point that
in this tiny little town
where everybody pretty
much thought the same stuff
to begin with.
Yeah.
And again, they might think
a little bit differently
about some things,
but like we developed this
mindset that we were different
even in this place that was so different
from everything else.
Mm-hm.
And I just had no idea what
was happening in my mind.
It's like, that is so...
I'm so happy I was able to let go of that.
Well, one of the things
was pride, you know like-
Just thinking that you're
the rightest of the right
of the right of the right of the right.
We definitely took pride in that and said,
okay, now I can...
"Through this lens, I
can understand who I am."
And when you find other people who think
exactly the same way,
it creates an incredible bond, you know.
And we'll talk about middle
school and high school
in two other episodes.
Mm-hm.
But yeah,
it's like this being established-
It fuels it.
Now in sort of that late
elementary school is what...
It's the reason that we ended
up staying such good friends
through all that and it's the reason
that we went to college together,
it's the reason that we
went on staff together,
it's the reason that we're
sitting right here at this table.
So I can be kind of like,
I can poke fun at it
or I can say that it's toxic in some ways
but we really owe
everything to the church.
You know.
♪ The Bible Tells Me So Show ♪
♪ Yeah, it's the place to be ♪
Yeah.
♪ You'll see. ♪
It's very catchy.
Did she write that?
I don't think she wrote any of it
but she was capable of it.
She's very capable.
I'm a little disappointed
you don't remember any of the songs.
I don't know how that's...
I wish I could repurpose
that part of my brain.
Dude, I don't remember the words
to any of our songs.
When we get ready to do a concert
I'm like, "Give me a few days,
I have to reacquaint myself
with every part of this."
But lines.
I mean, I don't know.
It's a different spot in my brain.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Maybe I should be more into musicals now
and maybe I could have a career in music.
You know what?
I thought about this,
I don't think it's music versus lines,
I think it's your long-term memory.
There's a part of your
brain that stores it
really, really effectively.
Yeah.
I have a really good short-term memory.
I have very bad long-term memory.
Mm-mm.
In terms of like lyrics like that.
So I do think this sets
up our next conversation,
you know, when we revisit this
and go into middle school.
I mean, because there's so...
You know, there were so many pressures
that then of puberty and-
A lot of pressure.
And dating.
Yeah.
Pressure in the pants.
Better pop that Zipper open.
So,
but there's different...
I think there's maybe,
and we've explored some of that,
but there's like other ways
to look at middle school.
Yeah, we're not just
gonna talk about erections
all the time.
And high school as we get back into that
but I think this is a
good start, you know,
I have a good appreciation
for how it's a combination
of so many circumstances
and like, in spite of our differences
that brought us together,
it's like we had these things
that mattered the most to us.
Yeah.
That brought us together
and they were the, you know,
and the amount of time
associated with those things
and those priorities really worked.
But I mean, you could be
sitting here with Matt McKinney
or even more likely, I could be, you know,
there were times...
Because like in the youth group
he was probably the other
guy that like at times,
like I really hit it
off with when you were,
you're in your basketball mode, you know.
Mm-hm.
'Cause he went to church with us.
Like, I don't know, you know,
if there's many other
people that, you know,
once you get in like fifth
grade that it could have been.
Yeah.
But it was...
It felt kind of preordained
to commandeer the term.
And there was...
and the thing I think
we'll talk more about
For us.
It in the next one,
but like the things that
we were finding funny-
oh yeah.
Like, 'cause we didn't even get into that
but like we were connecting
on how silly we were
and the things that we thought were funny.
Yeah.
And that was...
That was really the connection
between us and Ben too.
Like the three of us were so
silly to the point of like-
Yeah.
Just the level of silliness
was off the charts.
It would push other people off.
Yeah, people were like,
"These guys, there's
something wrong with them."
Yeah, it was like, they're
their own little club-
Right.
Of silliness.
Like weird to a degree.
It was inaccessible.
And I like,
and I really liked, I was like,
"Yeah, I'm super into sports
and I wanna be the best
at all this sports stuff
but I wanna be incredibly silly,"
and it's completely unreserved.
Like, we were completely
unreserved when we
were being stupid.
And I think we did...
That's the thing that we fully explored
in the Book of Mythicality
That-
Yeah.
That we really didn't
talk about as much here.
Because those early radio shows
and the stuff that we did
that was all in elementary school,
that was all very early.
Yeah.
We were doing that stuff at
my house with the jam box.
Probably not quite as
early as we think it was
but yeah, yeah.
Making those shows.
Yeah.
But look, I'm probably
fifth grade.
Fifth grade.
Yeah.
But so to tie a bow on this,
you know that the origin story
is at least parts mythology
and then the best friends
since first grade, it's like,
well, it's a little more
complicated than that.
There were some ins and outs
and some circumstantial things
in the elementary school years
but that as we were coming to
the elementary school years
were coming to a close
heading into middle school
I think it was...
We would both safely say
that we were each other's
best friends and it's
been that way ever since.
Yeah.
But that's not as clean...
Just like I a Link Neal bowl
cut right across the forehead
as saying best friends since first grade.
And you know what?
This is a special...
It's kinda like renewing our vows,
our best friendship vows,
that's another way to look at this thing.
We can have a ceremony.
Okay.
We'll put that on the society too.
And you know what?
There's another reason
this episode is special.
That's right.
I'm not gonna give a wreck.
This is our last recording with Kiko.
Yes.
That's right.
Kiko, we're gonna get a little sentimental
with you here, man.
Kiko joined us about five years ago
and has been working
exclusively on Ear Biscuits
for about four of those years, right?
So been here in the room,
he has listened to us
talk about so many things
and you know what?
He has to listen to it
when we talk about it now
and then he has to listen to
it again when he edits it.
Yeah.
Are you tired of us yet?
Is that why you're leaving?
So you got a great job
opportunity with Patreon
and we fully,
we fully bless.
Let's go churchy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're giving you blessings.
We're giving you blessings, Kiko.
We're going to send you over to Patreon
and then when you've had
your way with Patreon-
Whoa.
We want you to come back-
What?
Into the fold at anytime you want.
Had your way?
Yeah.
It's like, that's not right.
I don't remember anybody
saying that in church,
at least not from the pulpit.
The prodigal Kiko returns.
Yeah, we're...
First of all,
thanks for everything that you've done.
You've made this podcast
what it is in a lot of ways.
Yeah.
Thank you for protecting
us from things that we said
that came out wrong
that you caught before they went out.
Yes.
And Patreon is lucky to have you
and I know that we will stay in touch.
And you know what?
It's been truly inspiring to
see you develop professionally-
Yeah.
And as a person, like, you know,
we kind of an honor to know
you and to have been a part
of your life and to kinda
just to see who you are
and, you know,
we appreciate the things that
you've said about the impact
that we've had in this
experience has had on you,
and we want you to know that it absolutely
has gone the other way too.
You had a tremendous impact on us
and we will never forget it.
And we're not gonna forget you
because we're still gonna be in touch,
but thank you for
everything that you've done
to shape this podcast and
also to be an inspiration,
we've learned a lot from you.
So thank you.
Yeah, thanks, Kiko.
We're not gonna give you a
mic, so you can say anything.
All right.
So we're...
But we're gonna keep
doing this Ear Biscuits,
we're not gonna stop just
'cause you're leaving,
all right.
So yeah.
Yeah, so-
We'll speak at you next week.
Thanks to Kiko.
Good luck.
We know he is gonna be
successful wherever he goes.
Yep.
#EarBiscuits.
To watch more Ear Biscuits
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.